Well,
it's,
it's difficult to disentangle,
but you can,
you can think about it,
think about it this way.
Two ways.
One is there's almost nothing done in
Washington d C or on the campaign trail
without the media involved,
uh,
so that the media is constantly on the
mind of every politician and
policymaker.
The second way to think about it is that
the media both reflects and shapes any
policy debate.
So in some,
some cases that the framing,
the presentation,
uh,
of,
of an issue with in the news,
uh,
reflects how strategists are pushing
certain packages or a strategic
interpretations into the media coverage
or the nature of the debate that's going
on in Congress.
At other times,
something will appear in the media
around a focusing event,
say a natural disaster or a new
scientific moment or a will come up with
a new interpretation.
Sometimes journalists are kind of issue
entrepreneurs onto themselves.
They're actually pushing,
um,
a certain direction or a new
re-interpretation on policies.
And Your Times magazine article is a
good example.
Um,
and so in some cases the media can then
start a new narrative in the policy
debate,
a new frame.
Um,
but really you can think about
controlling media,
uh,
everything that goes on in an election,
everything that goes on in Washington
DC.
Fundamentally it comes down to first
controlling an attention,
how much attention in issue receives in
the press and then when it does receive
attention,
how's it defined or how is it framed?
Well,
I think,
I think the biggest challenge facing
science institutions today is the
problem of choice in the media system.
Uh,
so you can pray,
you can produce great scientific content
and produce really great science media
coverage of the New York Times coverage
on pbs.
But in most parts in those outlets,
you're probably only reaching an
audience who already agrees with you and
is already well informed.
The rest of the American public,
they have so many media choices that if
they lack of preference or interest in
science content,
they can completely avoid that really
good coverage.
So the challenge then is to try to
figure out,
in fact,
ways to what I call incidentally,
expose that wider public,
the science content to get them science
information and places in the media
where they're not looking for it.
So sometimes that's in celebrity news
coverage.
Uh,
sometimes that that's at a religious new
site.
Sometimes that's in late night comedy,
like the daily show,
um,
infotainment entertainment,
sometimes that's on the business beat
because many people that read the
business pages are not interested in
science or not also recent reading the
science,
uh,
pages.
Uh,
but if you can get coverage of science,
the business beat,
now you're reaching an important
audience.
Um,
so you have to figure out a way that,
uh,
where can you accidentally reach your
audience,
incidentally reached the intended
audience that you're trying to reach.
And then second,
that's the channel.
And then you have to figure out,
okay,
what's the message that fits with that
channel,
with that area of the media and also the
audience that's consuming that media.
Uh,
and again,
that's where you,
that's where you do the research,
uh,
on how to frame a present that complex
information in a way that's
understandable,
assessable and connects to something
that people already know.
Right.